Let's uh let's let's jump to this first
story let's get into it we have this uh
Twitter thread from Jessie single he
says because she is very on Twitter and
has Harvard in her bio Cara bio is seen
by journalists with no subject matter
expertise as a serious voice on
anti-disinformation counters counter
extremism stuff she spreads
disinformation all the time like
seemingly every new viral Lefty rumor
the story My Friends Andrew Tate's
arrest so as I mentioned you know in the
intro I'm in Savannah
we're in line at Leopold's Savannah
people know what I'm talking about
tourist ice cream it was really good by
the way but the line's massive Shane
Cashman is there he did this excellent
story on Carrie Lake's election lawsuit
he was there you got you really got to
read the story if you haven't I tweeted
about it it's on timcast.com but anyway
we're talking about we're talking about
Andrew Tate ten minutes later he's like
he's like walking around on his phone he
walks back over after I pull up Twitter
I see the story breaking and then I'm
just like dude did you hear and he's
like yeah what's going on like Andrew
take gets arrested for human trafficking
and so then all of a sudden this story
emerges he did this video in response to
Greta tunberg where he's smoking a cigar
and he's eating pizza and he says get me
some pizzas make sure the boxes aren't
recycled Alejandra carabayo a trans
woman posts Romanian authorities needed
proof that Andrew Tate was in the
country so they reportedly used his
social media posts his ridiculous video
yesterday featured a pizza from a
Romanian Pizza chain Jerry's Pizza
confirming he was in the country this is
absolutely epic this is outright
nonsense fact but the crazy thing to me
was when I saw that going viral I was
immediately like why would they need a
video of him eating pizza he flew in
he's on the Manifest when when there
when why they're flying private or
otherwise they provide a list of names
of people entering the country he'd have
to have a passport unless he like bribed
somebody but even then it's as if like
they needed proof he was in the country
to arrest them why would they need proof
use in the country either he's in the
country and they go arrest him or he's
not so what was the point of this tweet
just to make up a lie to post some
insane lie and then karabio says not
only did Greta tunberg destroy Andrew
Tate with her tweet she made him so
angry he inadvertently tipped off from
any authorities of his presence in
Romania with his lame comeback video the
dude has a complex in Romania he's got
he's got a massive building complex
this is this this is uh it's a hoax
but it's not just this one Story Jesse
single also points out car Bio Car bio
helps spread the rumor that the Club Q
shooting had a connection to anti-lgbtq
rhetoric still unproven and then that
story went viral like oh this person was
anti-lgbtq then it turns out the person
was non-binary and he says the same deal
with the power station attacks which
remain unsolved authorities are still
seeking a motive carbio gets viral
attention by suggesting some of the
attacks had to do with drag queen Story
Hour the crazy thing is this person this
trans activist speaks before Congress
literally just takes a random story and
then says oh it's because they hate
trans people and the media runs with it
this person is also cited as a Online
safety and disinformation expert so not
just does the media run with with all
the lies but they also they also use
Alejandra to
to talk about safety and and online
discipline in this information and it's
just bizarre that this person just
spreads all these hoaxes and I'll note
that these hoaxes actually have have
real world effects those the other two
um hoaxes that that were spread they
actually blame them on on me so I'm
getting tons of hate because you know
they're they said that that I caused the
the power outages because I posted about
that drag show and it has nothing to do
with drug right and it wasn't just me
getting hate there were other you know
other other big accounts also getting
getting hate for posting about those
events so this person is out here
spreading lies and we're we're getting a
lot of hate for it and it's and then the
media cites them and it's just totally
it's totally not true I want to talk
about Andrew Tate a little bit but I
first have to ask why do you think it is
that they hate you so much
I think it's a really big threat to them
when they see their own words being
being sad and being spread the way that
that it is but no no no I'm sorry that's
what I don't understand
a person says a thing and then you go
hey look this person said a thing and
they're like stop stop wait wait what
well not just that also they want to go
viral on Tech talk the reason they make
tick tocks is take a viral so they want
these videos to be shared and spread and
they want a ton of views but just not by
us do you like take it out of context
and just post the worst never I I I
don't edit the videos yeah do you just
take like tiny clips of of longer videos
and post like the most ways only if it's
like a 10 minute video you should have
responded to Tim's question by saying
you're a top G and there's a war on top
Keys going on right now is that what is
that what Tate said that's what people
in the comments sections are going after
yeah he's making vague kind of gestures
uh someone is tweeting for him obviously
because he's still being detained for 30
days in a Romanian jail so a lot of
people don't understand how how things
work in Romania they think it's very
similar to how it works in the United
States it's actually not the case I want
to kind of bring them back to what's
happening with Andrew Tate because in
Romania you have to be accused of a
crime you don't need probable cause
police could hold you for 24 hours and
of course investigate and check out your
premises and have search warrants but
but something very odd is happening here
because number one there's footage of
all of this being released to the
general public that's extremely strange
that's not standard protocol especially
when it comes to uh the raid and the
private rooms and the private you know
stuff that Andrew Tate has in in one of
his house I think there was five search
warrants on five different homes that
were being served all of those are on
video available for the general public
to see which is again something that
routinely doesn't happen and uh is is
not supposed to be going on during
during an ongoing investigation and
after those 24 hours a judge gets to
decide if he's going to be holding
someone a longer a judge could actually
hold someone for 180 days he decided to
hold Andrew Tate for 30 days and there's
a lot of fake news there's a lot of
disinformation we still don't know
exactly what happened here we're still
waiting for a lot of the information to
come forward but the media is running
with just absolute nonsensical bull crap
hit pieces and and they're talking about
oh there's large sums of money there was
some makeshift weapons I mean yeah the
guy was debanked yeah the guy has a high
profile of course you're going to have
cash around of course you're going to
have security of course you're going to
have weapons so it looks like looking at
the corporate media we're reporting on
this that they have a particular
narrative this is why they had to run
with the pizza box story and again the
Romanian authorities had to intervene on
that story and say specifically hey this
is inaccurate it was in the pizza box
that led to his arrest but uh there was
also someone who tweeted a couple months
ago saying that Andrew Tate was going to
be arrested at the end of 2023 because
the Romanian government was facing a lot
of pressure by the American authorities
and this brings me to the latest story
of what's happening in the Virgin
Islands which I hope we get to talk
about in just a little bit which is also
just as eye-opening and just as crazy uh
no no the U.S Virgin Islands attorney
general uh officially sued uh Chase uh
Chase Bank for being a part of this
larger trafficking operation of Epstein
and breaking the rules not reporting and
helping him Aid an Abed in his
international trafficking or operation
she was just fired by the way just
moments ago and the Biden Jill and Joe
Biden just flew there just flew there
and the U.S Virgin Islands are also
asking for a huge sum of money from the
federal government so all of that is
also happening right now which is just
crazy look as it pertains to Andrew Tate
I can just I just gotta say look I don't
know innocent until proven guilty let's
let's see the evidence I've heard clips
of him saying things that are shockingly
offensive but you know people ought to
be offensive but you know he talks about
having women do cam work for him because
they love him having having women who
don't love him doing cam work and then
demanding money I'll just say this man
if these allegations are true they
better throw the book at him right after
they finish that Maxwell case and we
figure out who is she was trafficking
into you know he's tits at the bottom of
the list
we've been sitting here for a few months
waiting for that Epstein Client List and
so priorities guys you know don't don't
jump the gun on this one I know Andrew
Tate big fish to fry but we're still
working on the Maxwell yeah yeah we're
so working on prince Andrew Bill Gates
Kevin Spacey uh Bill Clinton there's
still a lot of other people that we got
to get to Andrew
Epstein was one of Maxwell's clients she
would facilitate girls to different guys
and Epstein was one of them I mean it
goes deep on Elaine Maxwell Robert
Maxwell or Dad I just watched a
documentary on her over the over the
holiday you think she was the one who's
actually the enduring master and she is
so connected that they're not afraid
she's going to talk and they just put
her in this this cushy home detention
center where she's sitting whatever is
it so are you saying then in your
opinion Epstein was actually like
her play thing and she was giving him
the things he wanted but she was
actually in charge yeah and then when he
gets busted they're like he's gonna talk
and then for sure they thought he was
going to talk and in my opinion what
happened was her dad Robert Maxwell
Billy hundreds of millions of dollars
worth she would go around and hang out
with him everywhere he was her money boy
they lived the rich lifestyle he was
always her advisor he dies immediately
she hooks up with another money boy and
it's Jeffrey Epstein and she just ties
her life in with this guy and starts
feeding him young women because that's
what he likes well I just got I just
like that you know unless he's still
alive you know if these allegations
against Andrew Tate about human
trafficking are true like wow I'm gonna
be really angry in in 18 months when
they finally get through that entire
list that Luke just read off now let's
be real they're jumping the list well
now I'm offended it's like come on man
look all of these other people who are
very powerful and very wealthy who are
connected to Epstein we want the Epstein
Client List instead they're like oh you
know I Andrew Tate yeah he's he's
trafficking it's like oh all right well
before if we're gonna if we're gonna be
in that subject matter so who is who is
really pushing this narrative right this
person Alejandra carobayo mocking Andrew
Tate and all that stuff it's like hey
that's really great but anybody who
cares about trafficking is going to be
talking about Epstein or Maxwell Maxwell
keep it on Maxwell I think she's alive
she's definitely the ringleader I mean I
can't say definitely because I don't
know but if you look at like Maria
Farmer's you know memory of the thing is
GI Lane at the very center Elaine's the
money girl she's the the party animal
you know she just
follow the money have you ever seen
those conspiracies that Jeffrey Epstein
is still alive oh yeah yeah but there's
a conspiracy for everything yeah I don't
know what do you what do you think Luke
there's a there's a nice photo of him on
the uh maybe of him sorry excuse me of
of Drone footage of that island that
made me want to go there particularly
but uh that's oh that's a whole
different story I I think it's feasible
I think right now with how much the
government has lied how much they have
actually just screwed over the American
people with just how long they've been
running an international trafficking
operation 30 plus years that we know of
like anything anything's possible
exactly so right now Andrew trade is
also facing 20 years in jail if
convicted so he's still going to be
detained he might be detained even
longer from here uh and we're going to
find out exactly what's happening here
but but reading the Romanian kind of
press release on this that they're
talking about him being a lover boy
they're talking about him telling women
that he's going to be falling in love
with them and that allegedly is a crime
because he made them work on on an only
fan site so again if that's what they're
going after him for that's extremely
strange if there's going to be bigger
Bombshells obviously if someone does
something wrong they should be punished
for it obviously but a lot of people are
saying that this is too coincidental
that he has empowered a lot of people he
had he has made a lot of people think
independently and therefore now he's
being silenced and punished he's playing
along with that whoever is on his
Twitter account playing along with that
kind of narrative is he truly that mad
person that the media is making him out
to be well only time will tell but a lot
of people are saying it's very
suspicious that they're only
predominantly focusing and going after
him at this time uh when he's such an
important figure for so many important
people his brother too Tristan is
Tristan no but but the question is this
I mean one I don't trust the machine
when it pulls things like this uh well
I'll put his way innocent until proven
guilty I don't care any time but with
Julian Assange they make up fake sex
crimes against them which have been
washed away like the investigation's
over there's nothing to it but now he's
being held on Espionage charges so so
they were just trying to find a reason
to stop Julian from being able to do
work not and Andrew takes very different
he's a guy who goes on shows and talks
about all of his women and how he does
these things it's very very different
but I'm right away like you mean to tell
me you're so concerned about human
trafficking meanwhile Maxwell's Client
List is just nowhere to be found sorry I
don't believe it look I I I think maybe
they don't like the guy maybe there's
something to it maybe the accusations
could be true all that stuff fine but
I'm gonna lean towards doubt because
they Maxwell's there dude I just watched
The Client List and then go after him in
traffickers if you're really concerned
about him I watched a 50-minute uh Jimmy
Dore episode with this girl Whitney Webb
Whitney Webb is the Nexus of the Epstein
Maxwell information if you want to find
out she just wrote a book on it and it's
basically about one nation under
blackmail is the name of her new book
she according to Whitney Webb the ca has
been doing sex trafficking entrapment on
people since the 30s like they did it to
uh the head of the CIA what was or the
FBI what's that guy's name for 40 years
he he was found like you know doing some
sex acts on a guy they found him took
some pictures and uh yeah Kennedy they
had stuff on I mean and Kennedy wouldn't
play a ball according to Whitney Webb No
I just I highly recommend watching this
Jimmy Dore episode with Whitney Webb I
was gonna say why wouldn't they right if
we know the FBI is getting involved in
like the Whitmer stuff it's like getting
a bunch of getting like what do they
have like 14 agents and like two guys
and then convince them to go for a ride
along and stuff if they're going to
Stage fake Terror plots why wouldn't
they also try to Blackmail people yeah I
mean the FBI has been doing it since its
Inception especially under Edgar Hoover
and everything he was doing and Ian the
CIA was started in 1947 not in the 30s
but the CIA was also doing a lot of
crazy things like dosing people with
acid and and LSD and not telling them
that they were dosing them and running
larger human experiments uh MK Ultra uh
us Operation Paperclip there's so many
Sinister things that the intelligence
agencies have been doing throughout the
last few decades to think that they're
not doing it now when they were never
held accountable for it before is
absolutely naive and crazy I don't know
what do you think your line of work
because you see a lot of the stuff on
the front line you're seeing a lot of
this uh you know kind of larger
engineering by the intelligence agencies
on social media that promote a lot of
this nonsense
yeah I think that the specifically with
the Twitter files that that really
brought this out a lot it was really
interesting where they're so embedded
with big Tech which basically is
policing our speech
um it's just it's just so it's just so
insane that that that they're able to
have that much power over random
citizens I mean there's so much and then
the way that they were going after you
know moms at school board meetings and
and all that kind of stuff it's they
they're they're just they've been gone
unchecked for a decade and they probably
censored you yeah probably I mean I was
part of the Twitter files I I didn't see
anything specific with the FBI but I'm I
would not be surprised if that comes out
not yet thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time